Speaker 1: All right, let's talk about the
patriarchy a little bit.
This is the this is probably the favorite
topic of my audience.
My audience loves talking about the patriarchy.
No, that's not true.
So we're going to look at a clip.
It's an interesting clip.
Jason Whitlock was on Tucker Carlson's daytime
program.
Now, the difference between Tucker Carlson's
daytime program and nighttime program is that
Tucker wears less formal clothes on the daytime
program, but it's just as wacky.
It's it's really no different.
Jason Whitlock is a journalist who came from
the sports world and has become more and more
of a cultural critic.
The right wing really has taken to Jason Whitlock.
He's sort of like an anti woke tell it like
it is type guy.
And the things he tells, like they are as
he sees them, are very often wrong and extraordinarily
reactionary.
And Jason Whitlock on the Tucker program talked
about how not only is he probably a sexist,
but that the patriarchy is a good thing and
sort of like, it's all good because we need
to keep women in their roles.
Now this is a clip from 2022.
It's not a clip from 1952, and I know many
of you might say, Wow, the video quality is
so good for what we would expect to hear in
1952.
No, this is from this week.
And Tucker Carlson Tucker seems to know he
can't agree with the guest openly because
that could be problematic for him.
But he does the thing where you goes, he says.
That's not an opinion you're allowed to have
right now.
And so he's going to like indirectly saying,
like, Wow, that's an opinion you can really
get in trouble for, but I don't disagree with
it one bit.
So let's just get into the clip and then we'll
kind of pause as needed.
Speaker 3: But I probably am a sexist pig
so I could care less if I'm called it.
But the patriarchy
Speaker 1: now, he should be saying I couldn't
care less.
You would think of journalists like Jason
Whitlock would know that, but that's OK.
This isn't about that.
It's about the substance.
Speaker 3: The thing it's it's it's what God
intended.
Men are supposed to lead.
Men are supposed to be out front taking risks.
We're responsible.
You know, I have some ministers on my show
every Wednesday, and we talk about it all
the time.
And again, this if you have a biblical
Speaker 1: worldview, it's shocking that the
ministers agree with the patriarchal view
Speaker 3: in the guard Adam and Eve when
things go haywire.
God shows up and calls out, Adam, where are
you at?
Hey, basically says I'm excuse my language
bang right here.
Adam, what are you doing?
I left you in charge.
And this God is looking down at us right now.
Admin.
And just what are you doing?
Why are you laying down?
Why are you pretending that Hillary Clinton?
Kamala Harris?
Stacey Abrams?
Speaker 1: How do none of them know how to
pronounce Kamala Harris, by the way,
Speaker 3: that they can save us?
They can save this world?
This is lunacy.
It's out of her role completely.
And I'm sorry if that paints me as a sexist
pig, but it's what I believe.
Well, that's just, I mean, that's just an
epithet designed to make you be quiet.
Speaker 1: But I guess I right, Liz, you know,
when you talk about how these women are not
fit to lead because they're women and that
they're trying to be out of their roles when
people call you a sexist, they're just trying
to silence you.
It's just it's just an epithet.
Why wonder
Speaker 3: why?
Why is that?
Why are you not allowed to have that opinion?
Why is that so controversial?
That was the opinion of every society from
the beginning of time until about 20 minutes
ago.
Speaker 1: Now that is that is actually what
I want to focus on what Tucker says there.
There's this bigger movement about the natural
patriarchy, and this is a movement that wants
to explain what might appear to be unfair
inequality when it comes to gender or discrimination
against women.
They want to explain it away by saying there
is a natural patriarchy, whether it's biological
or genetic, or whatever the case may neurological.
And so that this is a very important movement.
And they wrongly believe the way Tucker Carlson
says that it's always been the way of humanity
until, as he says, 20 minutes ago, until the
woke era, until recently.
And it's just not true now.
As many of you know, I have no interest in
repeating tropes and talking points on this
show that aren't true.
So, for example, when?
You don't hear this anymore that much, because
I don't know, society has moved on, but remember
77 cents on the dollar.
You would always hear women make 77 cents
on the dollar compared to men.
It wasn't true.
And we studied it.
And what we found out was that women made
about 91 cents on the dollar.
Now it's still an inequality, and there's
a lot to look at.
And it's well when?
When.
What are some of the reasons why that is?
And let's explore it and what portion of that
is due to discrimination on gender basis and
what?
Listen, let's explore all of it.
But I'm not going to repeat 77 cents when
I know it to be 91 cents.
OK, so I have no attachment to any of these
talking points.
The natural patriarchy thing is just not true.
First of all, if you just look in the modern
era on jobs, there is no evidence that women
are less capable of jobs and social positions
that men predominantly hold.
I'm totally open to exploring interest level
in some of those positions among gender lines.
And when we talk about, well, there's certain
jobs that men versus women are more interested
in.
I'm totally fine having the conversation as
to whether the difference in interest is societally
imposed by stereotypes or for some inherent
reason, the right loves to say, Oh, leftists
don't want to ask these questions?
Ask them.
I mean, when you think back to the Larry Summers
Harvard comment about something about math
makes women less suited her like whatever,
he said.
I have no problem exploring whether there
is some basis on which women are less suited
to math.
I've seen no evidence that that's the case,
and so if we don't have evidence, we shouldn't
repeat it.
But the idea that these things are taboo,
they're not taboo for me.
And there is no evidence that women are less
capable of the jobs in social positions that
men predominantly hold that I have seen.
Now it's also fine to acknowledge there are
biological differences between men and women.
Biological men don't breast-feed, biological
men can't get pregnant.
But this idea of the natural state of the
patriarchy is a lame one, and it is also a
relatively recent thing.
There's some very interesting evidence that
patriarchal societies don't date back more
than 10000 years.
Humans appear to have been significantly egalitarian
for a very long time.
If you go back and look further, and one reason
that we suspect that is the relatively similar
size of human males and females.
Yes, human males are bigger than females,
but the disparity is much smaller of all of
the great apes.
And that is a clue.
It's not proof, but it's a clue that male
dominance does not seem to have been as important
a driving force in the development of humanity
as people like Tucker Carlson and Jason Whitlock
might might propose.
So, you know, it's not even clear I needed
to give this much explanation, but the things
which Jason Whitlock and Tucker are just kind
of casually ranting about and citing God and,
oh, you know, they don't allow you to say
this anymore, whatever.
These are topics of academic interest, and
we do actually know more than what Jason Whitlock,
pastor says or minister or whoever whoever
is on his show.
So, you know, I don't know that there's there's
much value in this program that Tucker does,
but they actually are raising interesting
topics.
Their understanding of them is completely
wrong.
But these are interesting topics, for sure.